hello georgia thank you so much for
joining us for this extraordinary moment
where we will bring together our two
candidates for the us senate
reverend rafael warnock and john ossoff
with the 44th president of the united
states
president barack obama but before i
bring them on i want to talk about why
we're here
you may remember a few weeks ago we did
something no one expected
we turned georgia blue we won this
election decisively
and despite the number of recounts it
keeps giving us the same answer
that georgia democrats showed up that
georgians showed up
and that we decided that we wanted to
move this nation in the right direction
that we needed leadership that
understood that the covet pandemic
deserves to be met with the ferocity and
the intentionality
of both science and a moral vision that
says that we can make things better
that we deserve justice in this nation
for every person
and that we are at a moment where our
economy desperately needs tending
and it cannot be simply measured by the
stock market it has to be measured by
what's happening to folks
at the supermarket we have a moment now
where we have a president-elect and joe
biden and the vice president
elect prom laharis but we're not done
yet
we're not done because we still need to
solidify
the us senate we have three branches of
government although sometimes it hasn't
seemed like it
but in the senate we have the
opportunity to match the needs
of the people with the power of our
leaders
and unfortunately for the state of
georgia we have had two leaders that
have been missing
in action two people who have decided to
put profit
above the people and two people who have
refused to take responsibility
for creating a culture of intimidation a
culture of fear
rather than cultivating a culture that
believes in our democracy
and is willing to fight to ensure that
every voice is heard
but i want to talk about what georgia
can do to make this right
you see we have two senate seats that
are up for grabs but we know how to win
those seats
we know how to knit together a coalition
of the willing
a coalition of the good a coalition of
georgians
who want to not only serve the needs of
their fellow citizens
but understand that we are part of
knitting together the fabric of our
nation
and re-knitting the promise of who we
can be
i'm excited because i know we can do it
because we've just seen it done
but we know this didn't happen overnight
we know it has taken years to pull
together
to lift up and indeed to mitigate the
harms that kept voices from being heard
but we did something miraculous in
november we built a coalition
that accomplished something that we
hadn't been able to do in 28
years but in this moment we know what's
going to happen
we know that we can continue to rely on
the new voices that have come from young
people
who surge from 14 to 16 of our
electorate
we can increase the participation of
asian american and pacific islander
voices
who between 2016 and 2020 increased
their participation
by 91 percent our latino
voices were amplified by 72 percent over
2020
african-american voices increased by 20
and the white share increased by 16 and
i list
every one of those communities because
no one community can do it alone
we are a nation that is built on our
diversity and we are a state that
reflects that diversity more than
any other battleground state ever has
and what we can do in this moment
is recognize that if we elect john
ossoff if we elect rafael warnock
we are electing the future we're
electing two men who have given their
lives to service who despite not having
the titles
have always been willing to do the work
two men that i count not only
as my candidates but as my friends and i
look forward to introducing you to each
of them
but for now i'm going to start with my
dear friend the reverend rafael warnock
i met reverend warnock 15 years ago when
he came to pastor ebenezer baptist
church
but i got to know him best in 2014 when
i launched a little project called the
new georgia project
to register the unregistered 800 000
people of color
when i reached out to rafael warnock and
said i need some help i need someone to
stand with me and talk about why this
matters
he didn't bulk he didn't blanch he not
only stepped up he
stood firm and he defended those voices
he has worked tirelessly throughout his
tenure as the pastor of ebenezer baptist
church
to ensure that the left behind and the
left
out do not get forgotten when he is in
the room and that's why we need to send
him to the u.s senate
because he understands that whether
we're talking about access to health
care
access to jobs or access to justice
that we need to have someone who's
understood what it means to be without
those things
and someone who will always put the
people over profit
and so please join me in welcoming my
friend and our next u.s senator
reverend rafael warnock
well thank you so very much stacy it's
always
great to be with you and i have enjoyed
over the years uh getting
uh into good trouble as john lewis
used to put it with you a good afternoon
georgia and thanks to everybody for
joining us today i'm honored
of course to be with stacey and uh with
john
uh in this fight together and all of us
are deeply honored as always to
be with president barack obama who
inspires us
all in so many ways i want to thank our
congresswoman nakima williams
congresswoman elect
and i want to thank atlanta's great
mayor keisha lance bottoms
for taking the time this afternoon to
help us to get out to vote
well i've been traveling all across the
state
i have been making my way into cities
and towns
and when i go into these small towns
often they're surprised that i'm there
i'm surprised that they're surprised
they say that they're not accustomed to
people running for the senate or serving
dropping by these little towns which is
strange to me because
john and i are running to be the next
two senators for the whole state of
georgia
and uh as i encounter people in their
stories
i've been thinking a whole lot lately
about my dad
i grew up as one of 12 children in
public housing we were short on money
but long on faith
and we had a deep sense of values and
hard work my dad used to wake me up
every morning seven days a week six a.m
and he'd say son get up get dressed
put your shoes on and get ready
and sometimes i didn't understand it was
saturday morning i said get ready for
what he said i don't know i'll figure it
out a little bit later but just get
ready
and he just wanted me to be ready and
that was a life lesson that i've taken
with me
all of my journey and i just want to say
to georgians this afternoon that it's
time for all of us to get ready
to put our shoes on uh the battle is not
over
uh we've got a race in front of us and
we intend to win
and we need all georgians to recognize
this deciding moment this is an
inflection point
in our country and georgia's at the
center of that inflection point
if you want to protect health care
coverage for the 1.8 million georgians
with the pre-existing condition
get your shoes on and get ready if you
want pandemic relief for the georgians
who've had to close their doors to the
dream business that they started from
scratch
put your shoes on and get ready if
you're concerned about our teachers and
our front line workers and their ability
to do the work that they're so deeply
committed to
is time for you to put your shoes on and
get ready
if you want a u.s senate that takes on
the challenges our country is facing
and will partner with president-elect
biden
and vice president-elect harris to
deliver
for georgia we need to put our shoes on
and get ready to vote the wind is at our
back
the momentum is with us the other side
knows it they're running scared and they
should be
but this is our moment we're delighted
that georgia's on everybody's mind
and we need all georgians to stand up in
this defining
moment in american history
and win the future for all of our
children again thank you all for joining
us
and i look forward to the conversation
thank you so much reverend warnock you
talked about getting ready and i want to
just point out that we've hit a
milestone in georgia already
where more than one million georgians
have applied for
absentee ballots and we encourage
everyone who
needs to make a plan to vote to go to
peachvote.com so you can apply for your
absentee ballot
find out about how early voting starts
in georgia on december 14th
and if you're not registered to vote yet
or if you've got someone who's going to
be 18 by january 5th
make certain that you go to that website
so you can learn how to get them
registered to vote
by december 7th one of the reasons we
need folks to get registered and to make
their plan
is to not only send rafael warnock to
the u.s senate but we always know we
need help
and the partner that he deserves the
partner that georgia deserves
is a young man that i had a chance to
meet for the first time in 2017.
i served as democratic leader and there
are a lot of folks who came by
my office to ask for my support for a
special election that was occurring in
2017
but what was so remarkable about john
ossoff was that he didn't just come with
a plan
he came with questions he wanted to know
about what he needed to do
to build the multi-racial multi-ethnic
multi-generational coalition
it would take to win that district and
what was so impressive about john was
not just that he asked for advice
he listened john makes it his mission to
understand as an investigative
journalist as a documentarian
as someone who runs a small business he
understands how important it is that we
not only ask the right questions
but that we listen to the answers we're
given and that we do
our best to make certain that right
always wins he is fighting a battle
against someone who spent six years
not meeting with his constituents not
serving the people
not being willing to answer the
questions but i know that with jon
ossoff as the next u.s senator
we will have a man working side by side
with rafael warnock who will always ask
georgians
what do we need and how can he help
please help me welcome
our next u.s senator john ossoff
thank you so so much stacy i love you
thank you
for what you've done for the state of
georgia throughout your career
building over these last 10 years
reverend it's an honor to run alongside
you and president obama what an honor to
have you with us today thank you for
lending a hand and for your support and
your friendship
my mother was about 23 years old
when she came to this country alone as
an immigrant
because for her america represented hope
she believed we were on a country on a
journey
making progress to fully realize
our founding ideals that we were equal
in god's eyes
that opportunity and rights were given
equally to all of us
that's the vision of this country that
drew my mother here as a young woman
she became an activist and marched for
the equal rights amendment she became a
businesswoman she became a citizen
because she recognized that the ballot
box is where we push this country
forward
and what happened in these last four
years as our country's been ripped apart
by fear and division broke my mother's
heart
and what's happened in this last year as
the catastrophic
failure of our leaders has compounded
the death toll and the economic damage
from this pandemic
has broken so many hearts but if you're
wondering what you've been feeling in
your heart these last four weeks maybe
an unfamiliar feeling that you haven't
felt in a while
that is called hope and it reminds us of
what we
felt 12 years ago when barack obama
ran for president at a time of war and
recession and financial crisis
and put hope in our hearts and georgia
right now represents
the hope of the nation because what's
happening in georgia
is such a beautiful clarification of
where the american south is
and where our state is you got the young
jewish journalist son of an immigrant
running alongside a black preacher who
holds dr
king's pulpit at ebenezer baptist church
leading a grassroots movement
for health jobs and justice
in the midst of a crisis and we're
running against
like the bonnie and clyde of political
corruption
in america who represent politicians who
put themselves over the people
we have the chance in georgia to stand
up and make a difference to define a
future
where all of us have equal justice under
the law
where all of us can get the health care
that we need to leave future generations
a clean
and beautiful planet to make sure
everyone has access to dignified work
that pays a living wage
to empower the health experts to get us
out of this crisis
and get economic relief to people who
need it that's what's on the line
i want to thank all of you from the
bottom of my heart
for being a part of this moment let's
make history
and win these races and write the next
chapter in american history together
thank you so much
stacy reverend and mr president
thank you john thank you so much for the
work you've been willing to do and the
way you've continued
to meet this moment it is my distinct
pleasure now to introduce
the reason we're all here and
i had the opportunity to first meet
him as a senator he was in the state of
georgia in 2007
we were in a small conference room
and i don't think i appreciated at that
moment just how extraordinary
the conversation i was able to have was
because barack obama
met with a group of us talking about his
vision
for the presidency but what he was
willing to do was to listen
to us to a group of state legislators as
we described the concerns in our
communities
as we talked about the fears of our
people and unlike
so many politicians who often interrupt
you to tell you what they think you
already need to know
he listened and more importantly because
he had been
in the state legislature because he was
a u.s senator
he took that information with him into
the white house
and for eight years we watched someone
who loved
not just the notion of america but the
people of our country
we watched him lead us through crisis we
watched him guide us
to better ideas and higher ideals
someone who brought with him his
training as an organizer
his commitment as a state legislator his
knowledge
as a constitutional scholar his
leadership as a u.s senator
but more importantly his ethic as just a
good
man who understands what it means to
stand up for others
to deliver on your promises but to
always tell the truth about what's
possible
but encouraging us always to dream about
what's
what stands before us there is nothing
inevitable about success
but what we saw with barack obama in
2008 and again in 2012
is what we have here in georgia in 2020
we have the opportunity to build a
better future
and there is no one better to talk about
why jon ossoff and rafael warnock
are part of that future than the great
man himself
president barack obama
thank you stacy you know uh
i've i need michelle to hear that
introduction because
sometimes you're not always a prophet in
your own land
but uh
you've been such a good friend uh but
more
importantly you've been such an
extraordinary leader
and it is wonderful to see
uh john and reverend
two candidates who
not only know their stuff
not only have specific plans around
advancing health jobs and justice
but have shown a lifetime commitment
to making sure that
all people have a seat at the table uh
who for a lifetime
have dedicated their life to service uh
who have displayed again
and again and again that
they care about people
including or maybe especially the least
of these
uh and uh
have the kind of integrity that
you know we want to see in public
service so uh it's a treat to be with
all of you i'm going to try to be
relatively brief so we
leave as much time for questions as
possible uh i think i have
uh a couple of jobs here
the first um
is to send a message from the nation
that we sure are proud of georgia
because the coalition that you
described stacy the
excitement commitment turnout
the insistence
uh on creating
uh coalitions rather than
divisions among people of different
backgrounds and
ethnicities and income brackets
uh and regions uh
all of that uh describes a vision of
what not just georgia can be but what
america can be
and you did so under some difficult
circumstances
because historically as we know it's not
as if
uh all the machinery of georgia
government
uh has done everything it can to ensure
encourage people to participate
in the voting process uh
and and so that kind of
movement spirit uh
combined with great
tactics and strategy and hard work
and a message about how
you know we need a politics that works
for ordinary people
not for insiders not for the high and
mighty but
for everybody for the single mom
who's working a a
a low-wage job uh but is committed to
making sure that
she's taking care of her kids and and
that their
her kids have a better future uh for the
retirees who are scrimping and scraping
and
trying to figure out how can they uh
you know live lives of dignity and
respect that reflects
a lifetime of work for the college
student that is worrying about
uh making sure that they can uh keep up
with their tuition payments uh and have
big dreams
but uh need a little bit of help to get
there
those were the folks that you inspired
that you worked on behalf
and what we saw in november was
georgia doing something that a lot of
folks didn't think was possible
and that's because not just of the three
folks that you know i'm i'm sharing this
zoom stage with
uh but all the unheralded
volunteers and workers and and
grassroots folks uh who who believed
and and so i my my first message
is thank you georgia because you
inspired us and you point the way
for the rest of the country
the second job i have is to say
uh you know the problem with doing such
a good job is i guess
you know folks come back and ask you to
do some more
and uh you are now
once again the center of our
uh civic universe because
the special election in georgia is going
to determine
ultimately the course of the biden
presidency
and whether joe biden and kamala harris
can
deliver legislatively all
the commitments they've made
and you know since i've got a reverend
with me here let me give you some
testimony
because i know something about the
importance
of the u.s senate some of the people
who are watching will recall the early
days of my presidency
others are too young that's okay
uh but
i could not be prouder of the track
record of what we accomplished
the affordable care act providing
millions of people health insurance who
didn't have it before and
setting the standard that says everybody
should have health insurance
and providing protections for
pre-existing conditions
you know us passing wall street reform
so that we wouldn't repeat some of the
outrageous behavior that we saw
on wall street that caused a financial
crisis and financial ruin
for so many on main street the work we
did
to save the economy from a great
depression
to trigger a whole renaissance of green
initiatives uh to help not just save the
planet but create
jobs and clean energy across the country
providing broadband lines into rural
communities
that didn't have it before so young
people could have the same advantages
that folks in the cities had
we very proud of the work we did
but even with
a big majority in the senate and the
house
it was still a struggle because the way
the u.s
senate is set up
it is possible for
those who want to stop progress
those who don't want everybody from
having health care
those who don't want uh to make sure
that we have
fair wages for our workers those who
aren't
interested in protecting the planet from
environmental degradation
that the senate is a place where
even with a big majority it's tough to
get
legislation through and if you don't
have a majority
if the senate is controlled by
republicans
who are interested in obstruction
and gridlock rather than progress
and helping people they can
block just about anything and so
although the first two years of my
presidency
were the most productive legislatively
since lyndon b johnson
once mitch mcconnell was controlling
that gavel and controlling the agenda in
the senate
we saw a lot of progress halt and
it slowed down our ability to recover it
slowed down
growth it slowed down our ability to get
uh
it to implement health care so that more
people
had uh access to affordable care and
protections
from insurance companies that didn't
want to give them coverage
and so the senate really matters
and one of the frustrations that i had
during my presidency was oftentimes
you know folks who were even my
supporters they'd say well you know what
look we got barack there now michelle
she's first lady
she looks pretty and she's doing great
work and you know
uh we trust them and so we don't have to
do anything now
and in fact then we got when we got to
the midterms it got even worse because
a bunch of our folks stopped voting
and we lost the house too
so i say all this i'm giving this
history
for a reason
the promise of the biden presidency and
the harris vice presidency rests in part
on
their ability to have a cooperative
posture with congress and to do that
we have to have the two gentlemen who
are running
for senate in georgia
rafael warnock and john also there to
help
move that agenda forward if we win
those two seats then you
have a 50 50 situation in the senate
and by the way uh i'm making here not
just a partisan statement
the good news if you have that kind of
50 50 situation is
it frees up some of those republicans
who know better
to say well maybe we should cooperate
the ones who are slightly more
independent-minded
and john and rafael are the kind of
uh big tent inclusive people
that can also have conversations across
the aisle
and get some cooperation so it's not
just that we need
those two seats in order for
democrats to control the agenda but it's
also i think these are the kinds of
gentlemen
who are going to be able to
create an atmosphere
of of cooperation
of progress uh and most of all
keeping the concerns of the american
people and the people at georgia first
and so i'm hoping that everybody
understands the urgency
of this upcoming election anybody who's
listening right now
you need to understand this is not just
about
georgia this is about america and this
is about the world
and it's in your power to in fact
uh have an impact
thank you so much mr president uh while
i have you here i'm gonna
take a moment and ask you our first
question
you you've just alluded to why this
moment is so important
but we keep hearing this phrase this is
the most important election of our
lifetime and we just
had that in november and you've given i
think an extraordinary description of
why the senate matters
but what's one additional difference
that you see
in this election for these two gentlemen
what does that mean for our country and
why should someone who is
still thinking about whether they should
get out or not what's the reason that
they should go
well i'm going to give a couple of
reasons real quick uh number one
uh you've got two candidates
in vermont warnock and john ossoff
who have shown themselves repeatedly
to operate at the highest levels of
integrity
and let's face it
you've got two incumbents senators
who in the midst of the worst public
health crisis
that any of us have seen in our
lifetimes
we know we're first and foremost
worried about their stock portfolio
goodness gracious
that alone should tell you something
i i mean somehow we've become ignored to
this kind of stuff
but when you've got a couple senators
who are downplaying a pandemic
towing the line of a president who
botches the response to the pandemic
despite the fact that my administration
had given
an actual playbook on how to deal with
pandemics
and then as they're downplaying it as
they're ignoring
the science and epidemiologists
and suggesting that you know this is uh
something that is some partisan
issue as opposed to something that
americans should rally around
at the same time behind closed doors
they're
calling their brokers
that's not public service
uh and and so that alone
should motivate i hope the people of
georgia to say we want somebody in there
who cares about us
and who's thinking about us and is
working for us every day it doesn't mean
that
berm warnock and john ossoff are going
to be perfect or they're going to solve
every problem of every georgian right
away as a consequence of
being elected any more than electing me
you know
solved every problem or that i didn't
make mistakes or or
uh you know that there were still issues
that were pending after eight years of
me being president but
the one thing i could say about my
presidency and the one thing i can say
about john and rafael for certain
is i know they're going to be working
every single day to make sure
that they are doing their absolute best
to serve the people that serve them
there
and that's the bare minimum that anybody
should should want
but beyond that as i said what is also
at stake is if we're going to get uh
significant economic relief for small
businesses in georgia that are suffering
because of the pandemic
if we're going to seriously deal with
the
aftermath of the pandemic if we are
going to
start building on the affordable care
act
and making it even stronger so more
people are reached
those kinds of agenda items require
legislative initiatives
and we can't get that done unless
we've got not just a white house but
also willing partners
in congress and these
two gentlemen uh john and and raphael
i know that that's what they want to get
done
thank you so we've got some questions
from folks from around the state and
john i'm going to come to you next
uh similar to the question i asked the
president you know you've been doing
you have this extraordinary commercial
with a young uh
with a business owner from preston
georgia and she talks about the
consequences of covid and the
consequences of failed leadership can
you talk about why you
think that this election is the most
important and
what's different about this moment yeah
and stacy that's
that's maryland crimes you probably met
her she runs mom's kitchen over in
preston and it's just a family business
and she she wanted to tell the people
that
what president obama just described
having so-called public servants more
concerned with enriching themselves
during a crisis
than delivering basic economic relief
for ordinary people is totally
unacceptable
i mean it's not just that
for example senator perdue has been
blocking relief for ordinary people
since mid-summer he was against it at
all in the first place
he fought against a single twelve
hundred dollar stimulus check
for working people while he was
furiously buying up
medical and vaccine stocks and dumping
his casino shares
while he had access to classified
briefings on covet 19 in the senate
it is such a gross abuse of power and
the story that marilyn wanted to tell us
here she is running
a family business she's not getting help
from the federal government
and the individual supposed to be
representing her isn't even
looking out for her he's looking out for
himself and the reason that this
election matters so much it's just like
president obama said we all know
mitch mcconnell's heart we all know that
he's going to try to do to joe and
kamala just
like he tried to do to president obama
and
partisan paralysis in a crisis like this
is totally untenable we've got to
empower health experts like georgia's
own cdc
we've got to rush the direct economic
relief they've been holding up since the
summer
to people who are suffering and our
opponents you know my opponent lives on
a private island behind three gates
the reverend's opponent's family
literally owns the company that owns the
new york stock exchange
they don't care about regular people and
they will be part of that gridlock and
obstructionism
at a moment when we need strong action
and a united front a united states of
america
to confront this public health crisis
and get us back on our feet economically
rafael i want to bring you into this
conversation you
have spent most of your adult life
starting when you were in high school
actually before you were an adult
thinking about the issues of health care
and this election is absolutely going to
be a referendum on health care can you
talk about why this moment
is so different and why it's so
incredibly important
that we have people who turn out and who
understand what's at stake
thank you well as you point out i've
been working on health care for years
um and when
president obama and others were pushing
through the affordable care act i was
preaching about it from the pulpit at
ebenezer reminding
the folks who gathered there that
if you just casually move through the
gospels
not going to have any trouble running
into a healing story jesus spent a lot
of time healing the sick
and the stories in our in our holy books
blind bartimaeus had a pre-existing
condition so did the woman with the
hemorrhage and i believe health care is
a human right
and it's certainly something the
wealthiest nation on the planet
can and often provide to all of its
citizens
and so we were making the argument then
and saying that we don't suffer from a
lack of resources but a lack of moral
imagination and political will to do the
right
thing and here we are all of these years
later and georgia is
one of only 12 states that is yet
uh to expand medicaid and so i've been
moving all across georgia and i go into
these rural
communities and they're the ones that
have been most devastated by our refusal
to expand medicaid
we're subsidizing health care in
illinois and
california and new york and our
hospitals are closing nine in the last
10 years so it was already an urgent
issue but the pandemic brought these
long-standing disparities in
healthcare and economic disparities into
sharper focus so that the people who are
already hurting or hurting
even more we should have known before
the pandemic
that i need my neighbor to be covered
that if
if if she is uncovered that that that
has implication not only for her family
but for mine
but when you're dealing with a deadly
airborne disease
suddenly we learned that we're as close
to each other's humanity
as a cough as a sneeze
that person might be uncovered but i'm
unprotected
we're tired as dr king said in a single
garment of destiny so
so the pandemic has brought it into
sharper focus
and has made it even more urgent and
uh we got to strengthen the affordable
care act
uh we've got to make sure that we get
more people covered
and we need representation in the senate
that's not
there to represent big pharma so that
while claiming to be the you know
captains of industry
and so committed to free enterprise you
don't want the pharmaceutical companies
to have to negotiate the cost of
prescription drugs
with medicare that doesn't make any
sense
and uh so this work needs to be done
it's urgent
and um i'm just honored to be a part of
that conversation
when we know now why we need to do this
let's talk about what we need to do and
i think that's going to be the most
the most meaningful part of this
conversation because
when we've got president obama we've got
reverend warnock and we've got john
ossoff you have an opportunity to tell
everyone watching and everyone who's
going to be replaying this
we want to give them three things to do
so i'm going to ask each of you to give
me
one thing that they can do to make
certain that we can meet this moment
and achieve the outcomes of you know
getting ready
and having hope and really continuing to
fix our country
so john i'm going to start with you
what's one thing you want people
watching
to do to make this happen
georgia and especially young people here
in georgia
make a plan to vote make a plan to vote
december 14th the first day of early
voting
vote for health and jobs and justice
vote to get us out of this crisis we can
pass a new civil rights act
we can make sure that everybody has the
health care they need we can protect our
environment
the future is limitless but we've got to
win these races it's going to come down
to youth turnout so i am calling on
young people in georgia
to make a plan to vote reverend warnock
and on that score i want to say that uh
young people who weren't who were not
eligible to vote on november 3rd if
you're 17 you'll be 18 by
election day you can still register you
have until
december the 7th just a couple more days
to get registered so register to vote uh
and then to everybody else make sure
that uh
you vote and make sure that everybody in
your circle votes
all of our faith leaders voter
participation
is a non-partisan exercise
it is something you can certainly push
from your pulpit
i believe that a vote is a kind of
prayer
for the kind of world that we want to
live in and so if you're sitting uh
in someone's temple church mosque
virtually these days
reach out to the leader of that
congregation
and make sure that we get the word out
through all of these networks our
our fraternities our sororities you see
i'm wearing my colors today it's
uh it's the anniversary of alpha phi
alpha but whatever fraternity or
sorority you're a part of actually i had
to give my brothers a shout out
uh make sure that you reach out through
these networks and get everybody
uh out to vote we can win this election
we have the coalition
if we show up we win
and president obama you you launched
so many uh coalitions and reset
the belief in what was possible for
millions of americans including
those of us here in georgia who have
been working so hard
to meet the vision that you've set
what's the thing that you want folks to
understand they need to do between now
and january 5th
to make the world the way we want it to
be
believe in your own power
you know the vote
is an expression that
what each of us does matter
and we live in a time and a world
where so often we are given the message
that
you have to be wealthy you have to be
powerful
you have to have connections
in order to have influence
but the premise of our nation
is all people
have a voice all people have power
in a government of by and for the people
and i think about our dear friend john
lewis
who's looking down on us who would have
thought that
a young man in his early 20s
with a kind of a
scruffy-looking overcoat and a backpack
standing at the front of a bridge
would end up
triggering a moral awakening
that transformed a nation
and yet that's what happened and and
that
was because he understood as
stacy and john and raphael
understand as i understood uh when i
started on this journey that
the faith that all of us
matter and all of us have a voice
when that catches fire
when that is something that we all
believe
amazing things happen impossible things
happen
uh and
and you are now anybody who's within the
sound of my voice
right now you have the possibility of
sparking that kind of change uh
and it's not by the way just by talking
to the converted
i mean one of the reasons that georgia
ended up voting after a recount after
recap
for joe bond and kamala harris was
because
there were a number of folks who decided
you know what
partisanship only goes so far at a
certain point
what matters is integrity and what
matters is values
what matters is how we treat each other
and i think there's still some folks in
in georgia who we may not anticipate
will vote for john and rafael they may
be your co-workers they may be
your fellow congregants they may be uh
somebody you know that you're a
a fellow parent at a school
who who if you have that conversation
with him
i think you may be able to persuade him
so so i want everybody to
i'm i'm assuming everybody who's
listening to this is going to vote
and i sure hope everybody who's
listening is going to get
everybody else that they know to vote in
their circle
but i also want you to to understand
your power and conviction
in reaching out
finding common ground and communicating
not just the importance of this election
but
the real possibilities of of what
america can do
on health jobs and justice when citizens
are active
when we understand that we don't leave
this to
the high and mighty but of us from the
ground up
uh decide we're going to make a change
when that happens nothing can stop it
uh so georgia get to work like remember
more knox said put on
put on some shoes put on some marching
shoes
i'll throw off those bedroom slippers
get out from under the covers
let's do some work and i'll i'll i'll do
anything i can to be helpful
uh in this process but ultimately this
is up to georgia
uh and and and and you know
the people like john and and raphael
representing georgia that's going to
make it happen
thank you so much mr president thank you
deeply from all of us here in georgia
you keep coming back and we keep
saying thank you for what you were doing
to keep georgia on
everyone's mind thank you john and
raphael i also want to take a moment and
thank the volunteers who are working
tirelessly
to keep georgia blue you're knocking on
doors safely
you are making phone calls you're
sending text messages and you're doing
what
these incredible leaders have asked you
to do you are making a plan to vote
you are reaching out to others to ensure
they've got a plan
and you're believing in your power and
if you will go to iwillvote.com you can
get more information about how you can
keep doing that work
because this election matters
but more importantly you matter the
people that
showed up in november can show up again
we can vote by mail
please go ahead and request your
absentee ballot we can vote in person
early starting december 14th
and we can vote on election day january
5th but it's incredibly important that
we
get to work now as the president told us
we have the power to change things and
if we will use that power
we will secure a future